wait a minute leads you can't put leads
down didn't you get your audition for
Harry Potter and Leeds we did what about
the football team not the city the
city's beautiful
good good uh the response do you
remember was it your idea or I mean how
old were you and whose idea was it to
for you guys to audition for this we
were we were 14 when we first auditioned
and we we learned about it because my
mum's friend got in touch with her and
just said you know what they're they're
doing uh open auditions for The Potter
movies
maybe maybe Oliver and James could go
along you know so we we went we thought
yeah sure why not it's on a Thursday so
it's like we missed school we get
possibly to being in the mate in you
know a film
and one experience so we found what
we've got to lose so we we went up to
Leeds which is about about two and a
half hours from where we grew up
and at this hotel
um they were auditioning for every role
so it was just
yeah there were thousands of people
there like going for all roles it's like
you know kids with lipstick lightning
these lightning marks on their forehead
days
really pushy show parents you must be my
daughter you must seem like that and
we're just there like we turn up we
suddenly real so you get like a
raffle ticket
obviously it's when you're raffle when
your numbers could you go to the guests
could do the audition and then we stood
down after about 20 minutes or so I
couldn't even realize that we all
realized that we were the only set of
identical twins who weren't wearing the
same clothes
which
in hindsight you think yeah you need to
look the same you'd go dressed the same
but this is how green we were to be the
whole process so we we darted across to
the
um to the department store over the road
and then bought just matching shirts
first matching shirts before we were
just like right to get those and wear it
and yeah and then we we eventually got
seen probably about three hours later or
so I'd say
um did our one line which was it was one
of Harry's lines I forget the exact line
and then yeah literally did that and
then they're like right okay off you go
thank you very much
a couple days later we got a phone call
um saying yeah we'd love to see the guys
at the main Studios the first world of
London and we Stacks you the the side
it's even before email I don't know four
emails readily available to everyone so
they've accessed the uh the slides and
then yeah that happened about three or
four times after that where we where
after we met um Chris Flemington
director David Heyman who produced it
and
and a couple of the other like casting
um people and then we had a we were then
we went away on our family vacation to
pull through or Crete one of the Greek
Islands after two weeks we were like
okay and just because before we flew out
they said oh yeah we really like to see
the guys when they get back and we're
sending like right okay so we know that
gingers don't pass
so we were you know Factor 100 living
under a umbrella the whole time trying
to stay out of the say I'm getting any
color
um and then we went back landed and then
the next day we went to our uh screen
test which was like on a on a set like
everyone everyone most people do you
know you did a screen test in front of
two what the chemistry is like on camera
and then yeah but I think the next day
or the day after they
um John Hudson who's the head coaching
director called my our house my master
and she said hi is that uh is that the
mum of friend George Weasley and then
that was it so a whirlwind probably
six weeks in total I'd say but mad mad
life changing event I mean did you guys
even want to act when you first started
were you acting
no
I did want to write but we won it wasn't
uh no one from our town did like it
wasn't a thing which whichever I never
saw it as a viable option of
of a career and so much so the the Drama
teacher at our school said don't take
drama for your essentially High School
level because you won't have a career in
it
um wow so I had great to like going back
to him after that summer and be like
well you know nothing how about this I
actually I actually told that story when
we we did um
one of the theme park rides have been
open at Universal in Florida and I told
that story and a couple of weeks later I
had a tweet from a a kid who went to my
who goes to my former school and said
this video has now been banned from
being shown in class because everybody
keeps playing it when said teacher was
sick like giving his advice on a
situation and they're like well you
don't know anything like this
excellent